Le 1er mai, c’est une tradition,
on offre un brin de muguet à l’élue de son cœur.
Ça porte bonheur !
A l’origine, ce geste est davantage censé déclencher
les sentiments chez celle qui reçoit les fleurs
plutôt que dévoiler ceux de celui qui les offre.
J’adore ce parfum. C’est frais.
On se croirait à la campagne,
au beau milieu de la verdure.
Une vraie « capsule de déconfiné ».
Il faut en profiter car ce parfum est insaisissable.
Le muguet ne produit en effet, ni essence, ni absolu.
Pour fabriquer cette note,
les parfumeurs doivent avoir recours
à d’autres senteurs.
Dans leur jargon,
ils disent que le muguet est une fleur muette.
Un comble pour une plante
qui est couverte de clochettes.
A qui je vais l’offrir ?
Tiens la petite caméra.
Si vous avez aimé cette vidéo,
n’hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu.
Vous pouvez également voir ou revoir
celles des jours précédents,
il suffit de cliquer sur le côté gauche.
J’en réalise un nouvelle chaque jour.
Alors pour être sûr de n’en louper aucune,
abonnez-vous et activez la clochette.
A demain et n‘oubliez pas :
nous sommes confinés mais on reste en lien.